last lecture was a let's say
work-in-progress one where I was
struggling sort of for every sentence
because I didn't quite know where it was
going and that is going to be balanced
today by a work of some certitude and
the two are related because the
puzzlement I have over what occurs in
the in the early medieval period in in
Europe are related to the to a sense I
have that after a certain point things
get tracked in a fairly coherent
direction that is sort of accommodates
all of the peculiarities of
uncertainties and yet exactly how you go
from the the enormous variety and
inconsistency heterogeneity and indeed
out an epoch yulie era T of early
medieval Europe into something that
appears to be more more coherent is not
clear to me except for the fact that it
seems to have a fundamental relationship
to an increase in population now
increases in population or decreases in
population are a obviously an important
variable in history and there's probably
no variable that is as mysterious when
historians talk about demographic
history they usually are able to
demonstrate that there is a change in
the in the food production sector of the
economy such that there either
is a greater
acreage of land put two crops or a
greater production per acre in the
calories generated in other words the
fundamental question that gets asked is
how were the people fed and and that I
seems fine that you say okay you
introduce potatoes or some other
high-calorie crop and now you can have
more people or for that matter you
invent Queen and barley farming now you
can have more people but can have more
people is different from causing there
to be more people I don't think that
anybody has ever engendered children
having some thought - I guess we have
just about enough oatmeal for one more
so you know maybe me and the missus will
you know try and squeeze one out
if you know it doesn't happen that way
and so the things that are often
described as causes are often equally
susceptible being simply analyzed as
concomitant if you and have more people
you have to have our food and
circumstances may change technically in
terms of the crops or the process of
growing food or something that make more
food possible the wider populations grow
this is
oddly uncommon as a historical question
perhaps because there's no obvious way
to to address it you know why why are
the populations of Europe and
particularly Eastern Europe falling why
are people not having children at the
rate they did you know 50 years ago you
know when we talk about something like
that in contemporary terms people talk
about the Oh for example how do you
expand your wealth available the wealth
available to a household you know does
education cost more therefore you'll
have fewer children do you want to spend
more money on the leading a good life
rather than having a bountiful family I
don't think anybody knows there are some
some measurable indicators that have to
do with age of marriage when the age of
marriage goes up population of this is
this discourages population to increase
because the seemingly because of
shortens Li the time period for
engendering children on the other hand
age of marriage is not the same for men
and women since a man's period of
engendering children can be much longer
than a woman's and particularly in a
polygamous society can you know a man in
of robust years so I say can be having
children by his you know F wife who's
you know
a young thing agent marriage isn't
always absolutely clear either when you
have a region like Europe that has a
substantial proportion of population
that is celibate
at least claim celibacy you know why
doesn't that act as a as a check done
population to increase more evidently
the argument is made from time to time
that the decline of the Mongols whom we
will get to anon but not today
has to do with the spread of of a type
of Buddhism into Mongolia that led to a
large portion of the male population
living in monasteries and therefore the
Mongols lost the demographic dynamism
that had led them to become the
conquerors of Eurasia that is not
certainly it's a it's a hypothesis you
also have puzzles in demography in
looking at what your indices are in
other words there's been a debate over
the early Islamic period
Andrew Watson wrote a book called the
Agricultural Revolution in early Islam
in which he argued that a whole you know
a whole cornucopia of new crops became
grown in the medieval Muslim world and
these crops
you know were accompanied by evidence of
a strong population growth the problem
is that the the crops were not staple
food crops you know true there was an
expansion of eggplant how much rabbit we
can you can you manage
you're trying raising a bunch of kids
you know cold Ocasio spreads when we
last have a yummy meal of colocasia
citrus fruits yes sugar sugar sprints
and early aslam rice but rice is rather
limited in the in the geography of the
arid zone in the number of places it can
be grown the one crop that appears to be
massively successful is the one I've
already talked about which is cotton
which is not a food crop which in fact
takes acreage out of production so the
question of there being a major change
in the agricultural landscape that
Andrew Watson raised that is sound the
question of it generating a growth and
population is more conjectural now the
evidence for that that he would adduce
would be the growth of large cities but
that is a questionable measure because
there is a get has to do with it with
the distribution of labor between rural
and urban enterprises you can have a
country in which 95 percent of the
population lives in farming villages or
a country in which 80 percent of the
population lives in farming villages and
that 15 percent difference are people
who've moved to the city and the two
countries are sustaining their
population just fine with no growth
growth and the overall numbers so my
response to Watson has been that I think
there was a that the urbanization of the
Middle East was a product of a
differential mind of a migration to
cities from a from an agricultural
countryside that led to a reduction in
the amount of labor
in the countryside and ultimately to a
certain fragility in the agricultural
regime so for example when you find East
African slaves who were brought in to
southern Iraq to to reclaim land by in
areas that were heavily salinated they
would shovel off the the saline topsoil
to get to non salty soil underneath you
say well why did you bring in African
slaves for that why not use the local
labor and if you have a growing
population and Baghdad it's interesting
that the number of villages on the
outskirts of Baghdad reduces it appears
to me a war of a differential migration
so in other words you're you have both
the question of cause and the question
of evidence now the person who has
probably done more than anyone else to
make the argument for a huge population
increase in medieval Europe is a Josiah
Russell of last generation a an eminent
demographic historian wrote a dense and
unappetizing monograph called late
ancient and medieval populations and his
specialty really in that work was tax
records and government revenues these
are much more abundant for Europe than
they are for most other parts of the
world and and they also involve
ambiguities for example very often a tax
rate would be assessed on the hearth
with
the hearth being understood to be a
family home but how big was the family
you if you're gonna have a standard
multiplier what is a multiplier you use
and there have been people who would use
a multiplier of eight and people would
use a multiplier of three and a half and
there's somebody using a multiplier of
eight we'll say well you have parents
and several children and maybe a grown
child living in the family and the
person pushing the lower number would
say that doesn't take care of old people
living alone it doesn't take care of a
new newly minted married couples who
have not yet had children and you have
to average all this out it's a it's a
puzzle the reason you often find strong
variation in the in estimates for the
population of pre-modern cities in
particular is the disagreement among
scholars on what constitutes a proper a
proper multiplier when you go from
number of hearts or a number of houses
the house density actually sometimes can
be estimated quite well from either if
it's a deserted site
archaeologically sometimes our aerial
photography where you can actually count
the number of foundations showing up on
aerial photograph from an abandoned
village or town for old cities that
still have more or less intact medieval
quarters you can actually go in and
count the number of houses so not
infrequently should say down freeway
from time to time
you're able to come up with a fairly
hard count of the number of places where
families lived but the multiplier still
remains very difficult but what Russell
did by looking at a very broad array of
tax data from all over Europe he was
able to show how the number of hearths
change over time without having to
commit himself to the question of what a
hearth was and when he found
consistencies showing that there was a
very substantial increase in population
the his arguments became quite quite
convincing to most historians and so the
standard idea now is that sometime from
let's say ten hundred onward there is a
very sharp rise in the population of
Europe possibly starting to for ten
hundred but you know we're using a very
broad brush here because we simply don't
have enough data to have a more plant
allistic approach the estimate is that
between ten hundred and the eve of the
Black Death in the 1340s that the
population of Europe doubled and that
the population of Western Europe that is
to say Western Europe excluding Spain
because the Muslim territories usually
get left out of this calculus the
population of Western Europe during that
period seems to have roughly tripled
work that has been done by David Herlihy
on the the countryside of Florence at
the time of the Renaissance indicated
that
the riot that land prices went up
indicating a higher yield financial
yield for what they produced these are
rural land prices but that the overall
production of the con tato of the
countryside around Florence only
produced enough food to feed the city of
Florence for five months of the year and
the rest food had to be imported again
broad-brush estimates but what it's
suggesting is of the population rise can
also be accompanied by a differential
between rural and urban so it isn't a
matter of that that a gross population
change automatically leads to bigger
cities or the population shrinkage
automatically is smaller cities or that
rural urban migration or the or the
contrary you know lead in other
directions you can have both at the same
time Russell wrote a book on medieval
areas and their cities in which he
divided Europe in particular and he also
did this for the Middle East for the
Islamic world into zones somewhat
arbitrarily defined by his sort of
subjective sense of what constituted a
geographic region and he produced
interesting evidence indicating that the
that you could rank the ten largest
communities in any zone in other words
that you would say okay well Paris will
let us say is the largest city in
northern France and then let us say that
you know then he would rank them down no
Toulouse is the second one or something
and and he would say now let's look at
the aggregate population of the ten
largest locations
and compare that to the total population
that we estimate from tax revenues for
the region and see what the ratio is and
he called this an urbanization index and
what he found was that in medieval
Europe the urbanization index that is to
say the pop the aggregate population of
ten largest settled areas in a region
compared with the the the total
population region Oh
will be on the order of eight to ten
percent other words we're dealing with
ninety percent of the population living
outside of cities in farming towns
villages and individual farm steps for
some areas the percentage could go up
into the end of the 20s and in
particular this worked for for Tuscany
in the Renaissance and for Flanders
where you know Gant and EEP and cities
like that became important industrial
production centers but he argued that in
those areas you had seaports that made
it possible to support the population by
importation of food so Russell really
shaped a lot of the thinking about this
and he argued that you have an increase
in population and you have an increase
in urbanization of the urbanization
increase is focused in areas that become
the centers for trade and manufacturing
and as a corollary cultural innovation
both in Arts and Letters in Renaissance
Italy and in the Northern Renaissance in
in the Low Countries with all of this
trickling rather more slowly into less
urbanized areas like Fran
in Britain all right so historians are
generally accepted there's a population
increase now what does the population
increase mean well it means that you
have an increase you have to have an
increase in food the increase in food
does not necessarily precede the
population increase it accompanies it
facilitates it you can identify factors
that are part of it
but it's hard to say that it's a cause
the particular aspect of the food
increase and this I should say has been
studied by numerous historians Lynn
White's
famous work on social change and
technology and social change in medieval
Europe
George Dubey's book on agricultural life
and medieval Europe European medieval is
just a wonderful wonderful work and
exploited a very substantial body of
sources and very imaginative and
valuable ways doesn't mean they always
ask the questions that you would ask if
you are not the European media list so I
don't know why the population increases
but I what I'm interested in is the
consequence of the increase there is an
increase in the demand for food
therefore we find increased acreage of
land under production particularly
associated with certain monastic
foundations that believe strongly in
bringing new land under cultivation
there's an increase in the use of crop
rotation and maneuvering that will
produce product it will raise
productivity
there is some innovation on the
technical side in the design of plows
making it possible to plow heavy wetland
efficiently as opposed to earlier plows
so-called scratch plows that were mainly
geared toward scratching a furrow in
comparatively dry soil so that increased
the acreage of land under production not
a whole lot of innovation in terms of of
what crops were grown now I mentioned
last time at this time period of ten
hundred to 1300 coincides with the
Medieval Warm Period and this is where
you get into the question of causation
if the technological changes and the
farming you know the number of acres
under cultivation are things that keep
step with population increase is it
possible that the improvement of the
climate is the causative factor is that
why the population grew from my point of
view as someone who is interested in the
in the reciprocal of this that is to say
populate climate deterioration in the
northern middle east and a decline in
population I think that's a really nifty
idea Europe gets warm and European start
to swarm Middle East gets cold and all
these noble arabs and persians become
scarce or on the ground it's a nice sort
of parallel but it's very hard to to
prove that particularly when you look
forward in time to the Little Ice Age
during which European population
positively exploded where it was getting
cold
or now when the populate when the
climate may well be getting warmer I
haven't read the latest blogs on the
fraud of climate change and maybe
somebody has proven that climate change
is indeed a conspiracy but the but all
these scientific data seem to point to
the fact that it's getting warmer at a
time when people are having fewer and
fewer children so you know it's tempting
to look at climate change as as your as
your trigger it may be easier to look at
it a trigger as a trigger for population
decline the population increase but it
all has to be controlled by what exactly
does climate change do crops are
flexible the mix of crops is flexible
maybe you simply change from one crop to
another to adapt to changing climates
let's say you take a crop for which like
wheat and barley winter wheat and barley
buy no favorite middle eastern example
you know you you plant in November the
plant sprouts in an early spring and it
grows and before it gets absolutely
torrid out you're harvesting that seems
to to work fine except that the
germination efficiency for winter cretin
buckwheat and barley is affected by the
soil temperature at the time of
germination so that if the soil is
warmer a larger percentage of the seeds
actually sprout and produce new plants
if the soil is frozen or chilly then the
germination is inefficient
you're you know fewer plants and the
yield in Grain goes down so here you
have something that is very sensitive to
to change in temperature now if you had
a soil thermometer you might be able to
determine something about this but of
course you didn't have soil thermometers
what you did have was an enormous
accumulated body of knowledge about
growing crops and that knowledge was
very often keyed to astronomical
phenomena like you know moon you know
constellations things like that so
peasants would say oh now we look at the
skies and we say now is the time when we
always do X and if the climate changes
maybe X should have been done two weeks
later or two weeks earlier but peasants
aren't stupid they adapt and so it's
hard to be sure what the effect of of
this is when you have climate improving
in Europe we see crops high yield crops
like wheat supposed to rye a growing
farther north in Europe because the
growing season has gotten long enough to
support let us say wheat growing in
Estonia but does that mean that you have
droughts in the south that might
compensate for it without a kind of
close reckoning of what crops are being
grown and the particulars as to how
those crops you know are affected by
changes in temperature and/or
precipitation you're still relying a lot
on guesswork - to see these things but
I'm willing to guess that the part that
the climate improvement in Europe was
conducive to the population and it was
conducive to that cause was conducive to
because that slippery was conducive to
the increase in population and so when
you see for example Vikings roaming all
over the place you think oh these
brigands you know going around sealing
things whereas you should be thinking
look at all those Swedes there are so
many Swedes you know where'd they all
come from well it was getting good in
Sweden and so people went robbing it
sometimes is used as an index so that
the Crusades are sometimes seen as being
caused in part by a surplus of younger
sons of the nobility who could not
inherit land and therefore went off to
seek their fortune by going to the
Middle East and hoping to to end up with
a grant of land in Syria or Lebanon or
or Palestine which many of them did so
sometimes the political arena seems to
be you know an area that signals
population increase or population
decline as I say there were no Iranians
who showed up to fight the Crusaders and
the later Mongols are pretty anemic
horde all right this isn't what I want
to talk about what I want to talk about
is waterwheels if you are growing more
grain because you have more people let
us assume that the people are consuming
a constant amount of grain now how do
you consume grain there are two
fundamental ways of consuming grain you
can boil it to make it soft and that's
basically grew
or oatmeal or something like that or you
can grind it and bake it and that's
bread it is likely that the per capita
consumption of bread grew and at the
time of the population growth and that
the need for milling grain which you
don't have to do to boil the grains the
need to mill the grain into flour
increased at a higher rate than the
population when you read the history of
of cooking for Europe one of the things
that is very clear that in the medieval
period though not in the late Roman
period but the medieval period the plate
that you had was a piece of bread via a
round flap of bread baked fairly hard
maybe an inch thick or something
and the you would use it as a plate and
then eventually you'd eat the plate as
opposed to the Roman period when you're
more likely to have a stew with cooked
grain with the onions a little lamb
maybe if you're lucky some basil
something nice and and you put it in a
bowl and you and you drink it or eat you
with a spoon let's say the coming of the
fork is is one of the interesting things
because there are you know there are no
Forks in the 10th century Forks are in
early Renaissance thing in Italy and
prior to that time you ate with a spoon
or with your fingers or with the knife
that you carried everybody carried a
knife all the time
as their basic eating implement
it has been argued and I'm not sure it's
true been arguing up that the rise of
the modern table knife is directly
associated with the court of louis xiv
because he prohibited the nobles from
killing each other on you know app at
and around versailles so he didn't want
people with sharp knives and so they
started to put knives after you place
with a dull end on them so that people
would not say haha my butter knife i'm
going to stab you it you know it may or
may not be true a lot of interesting new
work on the history of of cooking has
been coming out in recent years one of
the hot areas of research primarily
dealing with with europe the one book
for example on traditional foods of
indonesia is almost unreadable because
it deals with products you've never
heard of but i digress back to the issue
of a grinding grain the rate at which
the number of which mill water mills
increases appears to be substantially
greater than the rate of which the
population increases now i'm going to
read a little bit from a book that deals
with waterwheels by francis and joseph
geese book called a cathedral Forge and
waterwheel technology and invention of
the middle ages they say the tenth and
following centuries witnessed steady
progress and reclamation of unproductive
air unproductive areas by a drainage
irrigation and land clearance northern
and western Europe once sparsely
inhabited filled in the rapidly
multiplying written records supply a
wealth of statistics of which the most
telling is a figure given in in Domesday
book the survey prepared in England in
1086 at the order of William the
Conqueror
a century earlier that say in 986 fewer
than 100 mills are recorded in the
country that's England dooms a book
lists 5624 which is a low number since
the book is incomplete Continental
Records tell the similar story in the
old district in France 14 mills operated
in the 11th century 60 in the 12th and
nearly 200 in the 13th in Picardy 40
mills in 1080 grew to 245 by 11
75 in other words we're dealing here
with an order of magnitude growth that
is way greater than the doubling or the
tripling of the population indicated by
demographic historians now the important
part of this is that these are water
mills if you go back to we are 300 when
the Emperor Diocletian
published a an edict fixing wages and
more importantly prices throughout the
Roman Empire you can find out how much
it cost in the young in the 4th century
to to buy or build a mill because these
are our set prices a hand mill costs 250
denarii a hand mill at that time
consisted of a base stone and a stone
that fit on top of it that was your
rotating stone and there was a central
pivot for it and in the rotating stone
you would have a socket a hat a socket
in which you can put a handle
and you would turn the handle my hand
put the grain in between the stones and
that's the way you do it this is
different from a corn the corn is what
in Mexico is called a metate where you
have a stone and you have a stone roller
that you thought that was an ancient
system by the Roman period the rotary
hand mill seems to have replaced the
corn generally there's an intermediate
stage of the so called Homeric grill
bill that was a motion like this back
and forth rather than around Neverland
the rotary hand mill seems to cost 250
denarii
according to Diocletian if you had a
mill operated by a donkey that cost you
an extra thousand denarii so a donkey
mill was twelve hundred and fifty
denarii now a donkey mill obviously has
to be bigger than a hand mill often it
would at live let me say that the the
versions that we see at Pompeii and that
are described in the in the Golden Ass
of Apuleius I think indicate some things
something like that where you have your
your lower stone is a kind of a cone and
then you have a cap on top of it and as
your upper stone and the cap has an arm
that
and then the arms attached to a donkey
and the donkey goes around and around
you drop in your grain from the top and
the holes it goes down it's ground
between the two stones as the top stone
rotates on the bottom stone and it comes
out you know on the edges that kind of
mill cost $1,250 $1,250 t now that's not
including the cost of the animal that's
the installation price of the mill then
you have a horse mill horse Bell is not
much different it's fifteen hundred
denarii so it's only a digital 215
denarii because the Roman horse wasn't
all that much bigger than the Roman
donkey this is before the era of large
draft horses and war horses so you're
building essentially the same kind of
structure only scaling it up somewhat
for the for the horse then you have the
water mill water mill cost two thousand
denarii in other words it's almost ten
times as much as a hand mill and that is
a water mill that either was something
that dipped down into a flowing stream
and it was pushed by the current or it
was a horizontal thing where the current
pushed it around horizontally we know
that horizontal mills were common in the
Eastern Roman Empire because they were
they became the commonplace mills of
Byzantium more than the vertical mills
the vertical mills appear to have been
more in the Western Empire
I don't know why I'm the date are not
adequate to make it very clear whether
that is a generally acceptable
difference here you have a pivot and the
veins come out from the side of the
wheels for the field was around this way
and then that will turn a milk wheel up
here with the fun table you put the
grain in here it goes between the the
wheel is simply driving driving the
millstone it isn't itself the meals the
millstone so that's where horizontal
milk where you were the horizontal
motion of the rotation when the mill
matches the horizontal rotation of the
millstone for a vertical mill like this
you have to have a a gear that will
change the rotation from vertical to a
horizontal rotation it's not a very
complicated gearing assembly it is one
that gives you a little more control
over the power because the gear ratio
becomes them.they a variable whereas the
horizontal mill tends to simply depend
on the flow of the water the more
sophisticated mills with the later that
come to be built the period I'm talking
about will have a trough
above them water will flow through the
trough and come down and push the mill
around from the top so this is what you
had in Roman times called an under shot
mill and this is what you have in the
late medieval period that gets built in
such profusion and this is an overshot
mill the advantages that
this depends entirely upon the the
strength of the current whereas this
operates through gravity it's the weight
of the water as it comes down however
this requires that you have a fixed
source of of water and that's a Mill
Pond and then you have to dam a stream
in order to keep the mill pond full
because the the the quantity of water
and the Mill Pond
will determine the rate of flow of the
water that's coming through the trough
that's turning the wheel that lived in
the house that Jack built
it's crystal clear in other people's
drawings I last out in mine all right
so we find that Mills were well known in
the Roman period and of the four types
described a guy diocletian's edict three
of them were operated by muscle power a
human donkey or horse in the discussion
of Mills in the great period of increase
in Mills the sources in Europe make
virtually no mention of of any male
operated by animals there's seemingly
either no growth in horse operated or
oxen or donkey operated Mills or they
fall below the the threshold of
historical visibility for some reason
but what we're doing is that we're
increasing the milling of grain at a
phenomenal rate but we're not using
animal energy
now that's fine the kinetic energy of
falling water or the or of water flowing
in the stream is a kind of a free good
and you might say well why use muscle
power when water power is free
you know why use gasoline when solar and
wind are free
well you're used to it a certain way and
so you keep doing it that way even
though it doesn't make much sense but
there are problems for example a lot of
Europe you know house you know freezes
you know when it freezes you can operate
your mill and in some freezes because of
the expansion of the water
the freezing damages the mill you also
have droughts where you have problems of
sustaining the power of the water so
surviving mills in Europe down in the
early modern period commonly had
alternative harnessing systems so that
you could substitute animals for the
waterwheel unhook the waterwheel and
simply harness an animal to a beam that
would stick out from the side and use it
instead but basically the great increase
in milling of grain was not using
animals a number of explanations have
have been raised for this why were there
so many Mills it's argued that
monasteries and feudal lords built mills
and took a fee for using the mills that
they prohibited the use of hand mills
and course their peasants into using you
know John companies mill and that it was
a money-making thing that undoubtedly is
true and we have indications from
documents showing efforts to curtail the
use of OVA of hand mills but what isn't
at all clear as why animal mills weren't
used because animal power had been
available had been the primary source of
of
primary motive force for hundreds of
years and because the heritage of the
Roman Empire was that animal mills were
we're common now the answer to this I
would argue and here we get to the crux
of what I want to talk about that animal
animal mills weren't used because when
the population increases if you are
living in a geographical situation where
animals consume crops that are grown to
produce their fodder then humans and
animals are competing for acreage and
for calorie production in other words
your population increases presumably
with an upward increase in the price
that growers can get for their crop if
they're in a market situation but do
they really want to grow oats for the
horses and oxen instead of wheat for the
for the humans now this doesn't mean
that animal fodder wasn't grown it's
just an animal fodder was used to to
supply food for a military horses to
supply food for riding horses to supply
food for oxen that were used for plowing
land in other words there was a a high
continuous demand for animal fodder but
to increase that demand by greatly
increasing the use of animals to operate
mills would have made no sense
economically they simply cost too much
now the the interesting concomitant here
is that the investment costs the capital
cost of a water mill which you've
already seen was two thousand denarii or
almost double that of a donkey mill in
in the year 300 that capital cost
steadily goes up with innovations for
example if you have an overshot mill it
operates more efficiently but you have
not only the wheel and the and the
gearing and the attached mill stones but
you have the the sluice that brings the
water you have the the Mill Pond you
have the damming that you probably need
in order to keep the mill pond filled
because you're in Europe where it rains
all the time you have a mill house so
the whole thing is inside a structure
it's a very expensive operation this is
why these mills are mostly associated
with monasteries and and feudal lords if
you went back to Roman times you could
have said it would be a lot cheaper to
build 500 donkey mills than them to
build you know 30 large stone elaborate
mills of using water or a little bit
later windmills so but the investment
was worth it now for some reason people
were willing to invest money and that
investment coincides with the increase
in the population all right
now let's I want to look at the Islamic
side of things there is no increase in
water bills in the Muslim world
the Muslim world inherited the same
technological toolkit from the Romans
that Europe did that is to say every
type of mill that the Romans knew was
known in the Muslim world the need for
grinding grain was probably higher in
the Middle East per capita but we're
bread had long been a staple and where
gruel and porridge were less were less
common as means of making grain edible
but the population gillip the population
goes down and there's nothing special
happens in the area of milling milling
in the 10th century or in the 6th
century or in the 19th century appears
to have been pretty much the same
process you have a millstone on top of a
stationary stone you have a beam coming
out from the side of the millstone you
harness an animal to the beam and you
make the animal go round and round and
round and round until it drops and then
you buy another animal it is distributed
activity rather than a concentrated
activity the power of the millstone is
not really sufficient to to take all of
the grain for many many many users it
doesn't have the same power as a water
mill also people would rather bring
their grain to be ground to a nearby
locality than a distant one
so you find mills all over the place you
can still find them I mean you've got a
Middle East now and in the rural areas
and you'll find animal operated mills
not uncommonly depending on where you go
now the technology was not the problem
the Middle East did have windmills and
it did have water mills
and most of the of the derivative uses
of Mills water Mills that ultimately
lead to major industrial changes in
Europe originated with water mills in
the Middle East that's a trip hammers
and bellows operators and fooling mills
I'll get to that in a little bit
these were seem to have started out in
the Middle East and then to have been
developed in Europe so what I'm talking
about here is one of these things I
mentioned very early in the course the
idea of a transition from one energy
profile to another you're going from a
energy profile in which the the the use
of state that stationary labour as
opposed to transport stationary labour
goes from being animal sourced to being
water or wind sourced that is a huge
change the reason for this change I've
talked about from the European side now
let's look at it from the middle eastern
side a study that was done I think in 97
by an economist at University of
Pennsylvania looked at the cost of
operating a camel cart or a pack camel
in Pakistan the author had noted that if
you went to Karachi or certain other
places in Pakistan that on the streets
you found in the midst of all the
traffic
you found heavy loads being pulled in
carts drawn by a single camel usually
with a with a truck rear axle you can
see the hole where the differential
would go rubber tires I mean a modern
vehicle but pulled by a camel and so the
question he said was why is the camel
able to compete with a suzuki you know
minimal truck for carrying heavy loads
and so he worked out the budget for a
camel track we talked to camel drivers
have several associates from Pakistan
working with them they surveyed
providers of animal energy both pack
camels and layering camels and you know
cart pullers and any produces a sort of
budget sheet which shows you know let's
say 250 or maybe you know 250 laboring
days for the animal cost of fodder zero
then so many you know non labouring days
cost of fodder zero then he had cost of
medicines which was very modest then the
amortization had to say how much money
you had to put aside each year in order
to have enough money to buy your next
camel when this one died of course that
would be highly variable if you happen
to have contacts with a breeding tribe
where you might get your camel and much
a cheaper rate and then he added up and
say well so here's the profit and as
long as you plugged zeros into the
into the food thing animal labor became
like wind or water it was for all
intents and purposes free and the your
fixed investment was was fairly minimal
in other words the amortization cost for
a Suzuki truck it might last more years
or am I not but you're gonna cost more
to buy its replacement than you are to
either replace the camel or get a new
tire for your for your camel cart and he
and his colleagues concluded that as
long as fodder costs were zero that the
camel could or the donkey or the mule
but that you're you're laboring animal
could compete with mechanized transport
or gasoline engines for for most power
purposes but of course on the scale of
of the single animal so you couldn't
scale up you couldn't get a camel ten
size ten times the size of your own
cameras off they go
so it was clearly a small-scale
operation that suited rural areas or
areas with you know people who are more
comfortable with that kind of technology
and modern technology but basically what
he said is that that the modern energy
economy produces great efficiency in
this sort of situation only if you have
to feed the animals so then that raises
a question of why weren't they feeding
the cattle dogs they were feeding the
cattles it's just to feed the camels
they simply said go eat you know because
in the arid zone there is almost
unlimited acreage of plant producing
land that cannot be used to grow food
because there is enough rainfall
so whether it is whether you were in
Morocco or Iran or Northwest India or
Kazakhstan or Mongolia all the way
across the arid zone of Eurasia
afro-eurasia from the Atlantic to the
borders of China you have the
possibility and indeed you know almost
the inevitability of essentially free
animal labor from the point of view of
the cost of of upkeep but they noted
again and again and again I am books
about the Mongol conquest that the the
European Knight had his gives warhorse
and his number to warhorse and a pack
horse and his squire had a horse and a
pack horse so maybe he had three or four
animals who you take to campaign because
the bongos would bring along a string of
you know pen 20 horses now the Mongol
horses were not as strong as the
European horses they got tired faster
because they just ate grass they weren't
fed oats they weren't fed high high
energy feeds that had to be grown but
the Mongol could simply get off horse a
and get on horse B and then get off that
when he got a horse see that was the
common technique was that you swapped
horses because you had been T an
unlimited number of horses and they all
supported themselves from natural forage
and you simply switched from horse to
horse so the Mongols had a this
invincible cavalry that was technically
supported very different fashion from
the European now you could not wear
armor of the same weight as the
Europeans so the Europeans became
concentrated on the on the heavily
armored Knight on a large horse that
required purpose grown fodder whereas
the the arid zone people used horses
that were living off the economy of they
were more light
the armored but they had enormous
mobility and the cost of their animals
was was essentially free at a later time
this would also apply to the Sahel area
in Africa in Housel and where you had
horses with a cotton pad and armor and
so forth for a while it happened in
Somalia as well horses don't do well
that for our South but as long as you
can grow them on natural forage now for
laboring in the arid zone as opposed to
riding or warfare you don't usually use
a horse you use a an ox or a camel or a
donkey or a mule but in any of these
cases you're not paying for the food so
here we have a huge divergence between
Europe and the arid zone and that is
that Europe is shifting from using
animal power for stationary labor you
know and the arid zone is continuing to
use animal power the in Europe the
nature of the technology and of the
investment moves toward very large
permanent stone-built
installations in the arid zone you have
a widely distributed locally controlled
situation that simply services an
immediate need and the investment cost
is almost negligible now this has
consequences
the consequence that is the one I want
to to stress is that the Miller in
Europe becomes the wealthiest person in
the countryside other than the landowner
other words the the Lord is the one who
is rich and he may have put up the money
for the mill but the European
aristocracy despised work other than of
course chopping up their neighbors with
axes and spirits they didn't like
business they thought Commerce was tacky
they didn't engage in it but they were
happy to have an industrious Miller to
operate the mill on their property and
the Millers became their wealthiest
rural individuals who were non noble now
that I say world because in the towns
you have traders that become wealthy and
they traders may be wealthier the
Millers or you might have some crafts
like like being on metal workers that
produce more money but the thing about
the Millers is that they're distributed
throughout the society instead of just
being in these cities that really aren't
very numerous compared to the two the
bulk of the population so the Millers
become crucial now the action of a mill
can be changed from rotary to linear
let's say you have a wheel that's being
turned by water and a shaft over here if
you have a projecting cam on the shaft
and let's say you have a great big
hammer and a projection there as the
wheel turns
this projection forces this projection
up and then as soon as it get past a
certain point in the term the hammer
drops back down so now you have an
up-and-down action that is powered by
the the water if the power of the water
is strong enough this hammer can be very
heavy or you can a multiple hammers on
the same on the same axis with with cogs
that are lifting them and this is what's
called a trip hammer once you can do
that then you can have a paper mill
where you have to pound cloth in order
to macerate it and make it into a pulp
you can pound cotton or wool this is
called fooling and a fooling male-male
is essentially a hammer mill of this
sort you can pound iron the temperatures
that blacksmiths were able to achieve
back in 800 900 were not sufficient to
actually melt iron ore they turned it
into a red-hot you know malleable mass
called a balloon and in order to turn it
into useable iron you pounded it because
that forced the impurities out so a
blacksmith spent a lot of his time of a
hammer as you know eyes the image
pounding on on on a balloon then once
you've got an ingot out of that then you
could remelt that and make something out
of it but the pounding was a very
important part of metalworking so you
could have the crushing of ore or the
pounding of
of metal in a bloomery could be done by
water power you could have sugarcane
crushed by water power all of these you
could have a sawmill operated by water
power instead of having to go up and
down you have to go back and forth with
a saw blade all these things could be
done once you had water mills so now you
have Miller's
who become the the social basis for what
ultimately evolves into the industrial
revolution which is why early factories
were called Mills
know you've had a cotton mill or
something like that well it's because it
originates from from water mills
eventually steam and internal combustion
and electricity replace the water but up
well into the nineteenth century water
is your main your main source of of
power and the Millers are your key
social group now the role of the Miller
it gets talked about in European history
but what doesn't get talked about is the
comparison between the role of the
Miller in Europe and the role of the
Miller in the arid zone in to take a
rather simplified way of looking at
perhaps if you look at family names in
the United States today in from
different languages German French
Spanish Italian Russian Hungarian almost
any European language and you look for
two names the name that means Smith in
that language
and the name that means Miller in that
language you'll find that they're of
parallel importance
sometimes one bigger sometimes the other
but these are extremely common names and
Smith and Miller in English are in the
top 15 names in the entire country
the Millers become the an
entrepreneurial class if you look for
the Arabic name for Miller you don't
find it and yet the Arabic name for
Smith had dad is very common among
Arabic names in this country because the
Millers never amounted to squat in the
arid zone they were simply guys who had
a fairly simple device they attached an
animal to it and they would you know
grind or saw or pound or press something
with their mill but the scale was so
small and the profits were so modest and
the investment was so modest that you
did not have a social class emerging out
of the Miller's in Arabic the name for a
Miller is a tongue I think there are
only three families the United States
that have the surname Tehama and I think
they're also partic Jews who are who
probably brought it in from Spain where
they were following the European
standard so there is a you know going
back to the question of are there
certain things that you can that you can
argue that are going to come out a
certain way no matter what the variables
are and one of them may be that if you
if you go
to an energy shift that creates a class
that is wealthy industrious and
entrepreneurial you are going to have a
you know a proto modernization that may
develop as it does in Europe into an
industrial revolution no matter how many
monasteries you have no matter what the
evolution is of the of the relations
between aristocrats and kings no matter
what wars are going on you're having a
demographic / climatic / technological
shift that is I would argue going to
produce a long-term economic change
regardless pretty much of the of the
variables in other words it's not so
much path dependent it would I would say
probably have occurred elsewhere in the
world under under the similar
circumstances so those playing
contrasting but I'm talking about today
with why I was talking about on Tuesday
where I was stressing the the weirdness
of the variables this is something that
appears to me fairly solid it also gives
you a sort of real-world hands-on
explanation as to why Europe transforms
and the Middle East does not it's not
that the Middle East doesn't it's that
the arid zone doesn't it's the Middle
East of North Africa Central Asia the
arid zone that was blessed at a certain
period in history by having free food
for animals and so they conquered
everybody at a later point in history
the free food for animals came to be a
barrier because it meant that shifting
to water and wind which required such
huge capital investment was unnecessary
you had cheap animal power so in other
words what I'm suggesting is that what
occurred between ten hundred
1300 or so in Europe is an earlier
example of what is going on today with
cheap petroleum in other words the the
cost of moving to solar and wind and
nuclear compared with the incredibly low
price of petroleum is turning what was
once a blessing into a curse
and there's the possibility and I would
say the likelihood that whichever
country makes the transition to the
alternative energy sources first will
steal a march on the rest of the world
whether it's China or Brazil or wherever
it is because once you have created a
new institutional and economic structure
associated with your new energy profile
that particularly when that if that then
becomes a global izybelle energy style
now you have you you've got in a head
start on everybody else on on the energy
for the next generation and of course
here I'm obviously channeling Tom
Friedman except I don't think Tom
Friedman has grasped the real meaning of
what he's talking about but I am
convinced that I have something here and
this is what I'm writing at this moment
for for a chapter of a book and
hopefully it'll be done in the next few
days and once it's printed it will seem
true